welcome to the third Story Time with
Sadler and this time around I'm going to
be reading another short story one of my
all-time favorites it's one that I got
introduced to back in graduate school
when I went on a gram green reading
binge you could say
and this one is called the hint of an
explanation you can find it in a number
of places
particularly in this uh volume of short
stories where you can find all sorts of
cool ones but I think it's been
anthologized in many other places and
perhaps you'll see why so I'm going to
read it and then I'll tell you a little
bit about what I like about it you can
you know put questions or comments on in
the chat and I'll address them after we
get through the reading so with no
further Ado let's jump right into Graham
Green's classic short story the hint of
an explanation
a long train journey on a late December
evening in this new version of peace is
a dreary experience I suppose that my
fellow traveler and I could consider
ourselves lucky to have a compartment to
ourselves even though the heating
apparatus was not working even though
the Lights Went Out entirely in the
frequent Pennine tunnels and were too
dim anyway for us to read our books
without straining our eyes and though
there was no restaurant car to at least
give a change of scene
it was when we were trying
simultaneously to true the same kind of
dry Bond bought at the station buffet
that my companion and I came together
before that we had sat at opposite ends
of the carriage both muffled to the chin
and overcoats both bent low over type we
could barely make out but as I threw the
remains of my cake under the seat her
eyes met and he laid his book down
by the time that we were halfway to
Bedwell Junction we'd found an enormous
range of subjects for discussion
starting with buns and the weather we
had gone on to politics the government
Foreign Affairs the atom bomb and by an
inevitable progression God we had not
however become either shrill or acid my
companion who now sat opposite me
leaning a little forward so that our
knees nearly touched gave such an
impression of Serenity that it would
have been impossible to quarrel with him
however much our views differed and
differ they did profoundly
I'd soon realized I was speaking to a
Catholic to someone who believed how do
they put it in an omnipotent and
omniscient deity well I was what is
Loosely called an agnostic
I have a certain intuition which I do
not trust found it as it may well be on
childhood childish experiences and needs
that a God exists and I am surprised
occasionally and to believe by the
extraordinary coincidences that the set
our path like the traps set for leopards
in the jungle but initially I am
revolted a whole notion of a God who can
still abandon his creatures to the
enormities of free will I found myself
expressing this view to my companion who
listen quietly and with respect he made
no attempt to interrupt he showed none
of the impatience or the intellectual
arrogance I have grown to expect from
Catholics when the lights of a Wayside
station flashed across his face that had
escaped hitherto the Rays of the one
Globe working in the the compartment I
caught a glimpse suddenly of what I
stopped speaking so strong was the
impression I was carried back 10 years
to the other side of the great useless
conflict to a small town gift Source in
Normandy I was again for a moment
walking on the ancient battlements and
looking down across the gray roofs until
my eyes for some reason lit on one gray
Stoney back out of the many where the
face of a middle-aged man was pressed
against a window pane I suppose that
face has ceased to exist now just as I
believe the whole town with its medieval
memories has been reduced to Rubble
I remembered saying to myself with
astonishment
that man is Happy completely happy
I looked across the compartment at my
fellow traveler but his face was again
in Shadow
I said weekly when you think of what God
if there is a God allows it's not merely
the physical agonies but I think of the
corruption even of children
he said our view is so limited and I was
disappointed at the conventionality of
his reply he must have been aware of my
disappointment it was as though our
thoughts were huddled as closely as
ourselves for warmth for he went on
of course there is no answer here we
can't hints
and then the train roared into another
tunnel and the lights again went out it
was the longest tunnel yet we went
rocking down it and the cold seemed to
become more intense with the darkness
like an icy fog perhaps when one sense
of sight is robbed of sensation the
others grow more sensitive
when we emerged into the mere gray of
Night and the globe lit up once more I
could see that my companion was leaning
back in his seat
I repeated his last words as a question
hints
oh they mean very little and cold print
or cold speech he said shivering in his
overcoat and they mean nothing at all to
a human being other than the man who
catches them they are not scientific
evidence or evidence at all for that
matter events that don't somehow turn
out as they were intended by the human
actors I mean or by the thing behind the
human actors
the thing
the word Satan is so anthromorphic
I had to lean forward now I wanted to
hear what he had to say I am I really am
God knows open to conviction he said
one's words are so crude but I sometimes
feel pity for that thing it is so
continually finding the right weapon to
use against its enemy and the weapon
breaks in its own breast it sometimes
seems to me so
powerless you said something just now
about the corruption of children it
reminded me of something in my own
childhood
you are the first person except for one
that I have thought of telling it to
perhaps because you are anonymous
it's not a very long story and in a way
it's relevant
I said I'd like to hear it
you mustn't expect too much meaning but
to me there seems to be a hint that's
all a hint
he went slowly on
turning his face to the pain though he
could have seen nothing real in the
whirling World outside except an
occasional signal lamp a light in a
window a small country station torn
backwards by our Rush picking his words
with precision
he said
when I was a child they taught me to
serve at Mass the church was a small one
for there were very few Catholics where
I lived it was a market town in East
Anglia surrounded by flat chalky fields
and ditches so many ditches I don't
suppose there were 50 Catholics all told
and for some reason there was a
tradition of hostility to to us perhaps
it went back to the burning of a
Protestant martyr in the 16th century
there was a stone marking the place near
where the meat stalls stood on
Wednesdays
I was only half aware of the amnity
though I knew my school nickname of
popey Martin had something to do with my
religion and I'd heard that my father
was nearly excluded from the
Constitutional Club when he first came
to town
every Sunday I had to dress up in my
Surplus and serve Mass I hated it I have
always hated dressing up in any way
which is funny when you come to think of
it and I never cease to be afraid of
losing my place in the service and doing
something which would put me to ridicule
our services were at a different hour
from the Anglican and as our smaller
small far from select band trudged under
the Hideous Chapel the whole of the Town
folks seemed to be on the way past to
the proper church I always thought of it
as the proper Church
we had to pass the parade of their eyes
indifferent supercilious mocking you
can't imagine how seriously religion can
be taken in a small town if only for
social reasons
there was one man in particular he was
one of the two Bakers in the town the
one my family did not patronize I I
don't think any of the Catholics
patronized him because he was called a
free thinker an odd title for poor man
no one's thoughts were less free than
his he was hemmed in by his hatred his
hatred of us he was very ugly to look at
with one walleye and I had the shape of
a turnip with a hair gone on the crown
and he was unmarried he had no interest
apparently but his baking and his hatred
though now I am older I begin to see
other sides to his nature it did contain
perhaps a certain furtive love
one would come across him suddenly
sometimes on a Country Walk especially
if one were alone and it were Sunday it
was if he rose from the ditches and the
smear of chalk on his clothes reminded
one of the flower on his working
overalls
he would have a stick in his hand and
stab at the hedges and if his mood were
very black he would call out after one
strange abrupt words like a foreign
tongue I know the meaning of those words
of course now once the police went to
his house because of what a boy said
he'd seen but nothing came of it except
the hate Shackled him closer his name
was blacker and he terrified me
I think he had a particular hatred of my
father I don't know why my father was
manager of the Midland bank and it's
possible that sometime black or may have
had unsatisfactory dealings with the
bank my father was a very cautious man
who suffered all his life from anxiety
about money his own and other people's
if I try and picture blacker now I see
him walking along a narrowing path
between High windowless walls and at the
end of the path stands a small boy of
ten me
I don't know whether it's a symbolic
picture or the memory of one of our
encounters
one our encounters somehow got more and
more frequent you talked just now about
the corruption of children that poor man
Was preparing to Revenge himself on
everything he hated my father the
Catholics The God Who people persisted
in crediting and that by corrupting me
he had evolved a horrible and ingenious
plan
thank you
I remember the first time I had a
friendly word from him
I was passing his shop as rapidly as I
could when I heard his voice call out
with a kind of Sly subservience as
though he were an underservant Master
David he called Master David and I
hurried on but the next time I passed
that way he was at his door he must have
seen me coming with one of those curly
cakes in his hand that we called Chelsea
buttons
I didn't want to take it but he made me
and then I couldn't be other than polite
when he asked me to come into His parlor
because behind the shop and see
something very special
it was a small electric Railway a rare
sight in those days and he insisted on
showing me how it worked he made me turn
the switches and stop and start it and
he told me I could come in any morning
and have a game with it he used the word
game as though it were something secret
and it's true I never told my family of
this invitation and how perhaps twice a
week those holidays the desire to
control that little Railway became
overpowering and looking up and down the
street to see whether I were observed I
would dive into the shop
are large or dirtier adult train drove
into a tunnel and the light went out we
sat in darkness and Silence with the
noise of the train blocking our ears
like Wax
when we were through he didn't we didn't
speak at once then I had to prick him
into continuing
an elaborate seduction I said
don't think his plans were as simple as
that my companion said or as crude there
was much more hate than love poor man in
his makeup can you hate something you
don't believe in and yet he called
himself a free thinker what an
impossible Paradox to be free and to be
so obsessed day by day all through those
holidays his obsession must have grown
but he kept a grip he bided his time
perhaps that thing I spoke of gave him
the strength and wisdom it was only a
week from the end of the holidays he
spoke to me on what concerned him so
deeply
I heard him behind me as I knelt on the
floor coupling to coaches he said you
won't be able to do this master David
when school starts it wasn't a sentence
that needed any comment for me any more
than the one that followed you ought to
have it for your own you ought
but how skillfully and unemphatically he
had sowed the longing the idea of a
possibility I was coming to his parlor
every day now you see I had to cram
every opportunity in before they hated
term started again I suppose I was
becoming accustomed to black or to that
walleye that turnip had that nauseating
subservience the pope you know describes
himself as the servant of the Servants
of God and black or I sometimes think
that blacker was the servant of the
Servants of
well let it be
the very next day
standing in the doorway watching me play
he began to talk to me about religion he
said with what untruth even I recognized
how much he admired the Catholics he
wished he could believe like that but
how could a baker believe he accented a
baker as one might say a biologist and
the tiny train spun around the Gage o
track he said
I I can bake the things you eat just as
well as any Catholic can and disappeared
into his shop
I hadn't the faintest idea what he meant
presently he emerged again holding in
his hand a little wafer
here he said eat that and tell me
when I put it in my mouth I could tell
that it was made in the same way as our
Wafers for communion he got the shape a
little wrong that was all and I felt
guilty and irrationally scared
me what's the difference
difference I asked isn't that just the
same as you eat in church I said smugly
it hasn't been consecrated
he said do you think if I put the two of
them under a microscope you could tell
the difference
but even at 10 I had an answer to the
question no I said the accidents don't
change stubbling a little bit on the
word accidents which had suddenly
conveyed to me the idea of death and
wounds
blacker said with sudden intensity
how I'd like to get one of the very
first time that the idea of
transubstantiation really lodged in my
mind I'd learned it all by wrote I'd
grown up with the idea the mass was as
lifeless to me as the sentence is and
Below galico communion a routine like
real in the schoolyard
but suddenly I was in the presence of a
man who took it seriously as seriously
as the priest who naturally one didn't
count it was his job
felt more scared than ever
he said it's all nonsense but I'd like
I'd just like to have it in my mouth
well you could if you were a Catholic I
said naively
he gazed at me with his one good eye
like a cyclops he said you serve at Mass
don't you it would be easy for you to
get one of those things I'll tell you
what I do I'd Swap this electric train
for one of your Wafers consecrated mind
it's got to be consecrated
I could get you one out of the box I
said I think I still imagined his
interest was a Baker's interest just to
see how they were made
oh no he said I want to see what your
God tastes like
I couldn't do that
not for a whole electric train just for
yourself
you wouldn't have any trouble at home
I'd pack it up and put a label inside
that your dad could see for my bank
manager's little boy from a grateful
client he'd be pleased this punch with
that
now that we are grown men it seems a
trivial Temptation doesn't it but try to
think back to your own childhood there
was a whole Circuit of rails there on
the floor at our feet straight rails and
curved and a little station with Porters
and passion passengers a tunnel a
Footbridge a level crossing two signals
buffers of course and above all a
turntable
the tears of longing came into my eyes
when I looked at the turntable it was my
favorite piece it looked so ugly and
practical and true
I said weekly
I wouldn't know how
how carefully he'd been studying the
ground he must have slipped several
times into mass at the back of the
church it would have been no good you
understand a little town like that
presenting himself for communion
everybody there knew him for what he was
he said to me when you've been given
communion you could just put it under
your tongue a moment he serves you and
the other boy first and I saw you once
go out behind the curtain straight
afterwards you'd forgotten one of the
little bottles the cruet I said pepper
and salt he grinned at me jovalee and I
well I looked at the little Railway
which I could no longer come and play
with when the term started I said you
just swallow it wouldn't you oh yes he
said I just swallow it
somehow I didn't want to play with the
train anymore that day I got up and made
for the door but he detained me gripping
my lapel he said this will be a secret
between you and me tomorrow's Sunday you
come along here in the afternoon put it
in an envelope and posted me Monday
morning the train will be delivered
bright and early
not tomorrow I implored him I'm not
interested in any other Sunday he said
it's your only chance
he shook me gently backwards and
forwards it will always have to be a
secret between you and me who said why
if anyone knew they'd take away the
train and there'd be me to reckon with
I'd bleed you something awful you know
how I'm always about on Sunday walks you
can't avoid a man like me I crop up you
wouldn't ever be safe even in your own
house I know ways to get into houses
when people are asleep
he pulled me into the shop after him and
opened up a drawer in the drawer was an
odd looking key and a Cutthroat razor he
said that's a master key that opens all
locks and that that's what I bleed
people with then he patted my cheek with
his plump flowery fingers and said
forget it you and me are friends
that Sunday mass stays in my head every
detail of it as though it happened only
a week ago from the moment of the
confession to the moment of consecration
it had a terrible importance only one
other Mass has ever been so important to
me perhaps not even one for this was a
solitary Mass which would never happen
again it seemed as final as the last
Sacrament when the priest bent down and
put the wafer in my mouth where I knelt
before the altar with my fellow server
I suppose I had made up my mind to
commit this awful act for you know to us
it must always seem an awful act from
the moment when I saw black or watching
from the back of the church he'd put on
his best black Sunday clothes and though
he could never quite escape the smear of
his profession he had a draw a dab of
dried talcum on his cheek which he had
presumably applied after using that
Cutthroat of his
he was watching me closely all the time
and I think it was fear fear of that
terrible undefined thing called bleeding
as much as coveted covetousness that
drove me to carry out my instructions
my fellow server got briskly up and
taking the patent preceded father carry
to the altar rail where the other
communicants melt I had the host lodged
under my tongue it felt like a blister I
got up and made for the curtain to get
the cruet I'd purposefully left in the
Sacristy when I was there I looked
quickly around for a hiding place and I
saw an old copy of the universe lying on
a chair I took the host from my mouth
and inserted it between two sheets a
little damp mess of Pulp then I thought
perhaps father Kerry has put out the
paper for a particular purpose and he
will find the host before I have time to
remove it and the enormity of my ACT
began to come home to me when I tried to
imagine what punishment I should incur
murder is sufficiently Trivial to have
its appropriate punishment but for this
act the mind boggled at the thought of
any retribution at all
I tried to remove the host but it stuck
clamly between the pages and in
desperation I tore out a piece of the
newspaper and screwing the whole thing
up stuck it in my trouser's pocket
when I came back through the curtain
carrying the crew at my eyes met
blackers
he gave me a grin of encouragement and
unhappiness yes I am sure unhappiness
was it perhaps the poor man was all the
time seeking something incorruptible
I can remember a little more of that day
I think my mind was shocked and stunned
and I was caught up two in the family
bustle of Sunday Sunday in a provincial
town is the day for relations all the
family are at home and unfamiliar
cousins and uncles are apt to arrive
packed in the back seats of others cars
I remember that some crowd of the kind
descended on us and pushed black or
temporarily out of the foreground in my
mind there was somebody called Aunt Lucy
with a loud Hollow laugh that filled the
house with mechanical merriment like the
sound of recorded laughter from inside a
Hall of Mirrors and I had no opportunity
to go out alone even if I had wished to
when six o'clock came and Aunt Lucy and
the cousins departed and peace returned
it was too late to go to blackers and at
eight it was my own bedtime
I think I'd have forgotten what I had in
my pocket
as I emptied my pocket the little screw
of newspaper brought back quickly the
mass the pre-spending over me blacker's
grin I laid the packet on the chair by
my bed and tried to go to sleep but I
was haunted by the Shadows on the wall
where the curtains blew the squeak of
furniture the Russell in the chimney
haunted by the presence of God there on
the chair the host had always been to me
well the host
I knew theoretically as I've said what I
had to believe but suddenly as someone
whistled in the road outside whistled
secretively knowingly to me
I knew that this which I had beside my
bed was something of infinite value
something a man would pay for with his
whole Peace of Mind something that was
so hated that one could love it as one
loves an outcast or a bullied child
these are adult words and it was a child
of ten who lay scared in bed listening
to the whistle from the road blackers
whistle
but I think
he felt fairly clearly what I am
describing now
that is what I meant when I said that
this thing whatever it is that seizes
every possible weapon against God is
always everywhere disappointed at the
moment of success it must have felt it
as certain of me as black or did it must
have felt certain too a Blacker
but I wonder if one knew what happened
later to that poor man whether one would
not find again that weapon had been
turned against its own breast
At Last I couldn't bear that whistle
anymore and got out of bed I opened the
curtains a little way and they're right
under my window The Moonlight on his
face was blacker if I had stretched my
hand down his fingers reaching up could
almost have touched mine he looked up at
me flashing the one good eye with hunger
I realize now that near success must
have developed his obsession almost to
the point of Madness desperation had
driven him to the house he whispered up
at me David where is it I jerked my head
into back at the room give it me he said
quick you shall have the train in the
morning
I shook my head he said
I've got the bleeder here and the key
you'd better toss it down
go away I said but I could hardly speak
for fear
I'll bleed you first and then I'll have
it just the same
oh no you won't I said I went to the
chair and picked it him up there was
only one place where he was safe
I couldn't separate the host from the
paper so I swallowed both
the newsprint Stuck Like A pruned skin
to the back of my throat but I rinsed it
down with water from the ewer then I
went back to the window and looked down
at Blacker
he began to Weedle me
what have you done with it David what's
the fuss it's only a bit of bread
looking so longingly and pleadingly up
at me that even as a child I wondered
whether he could really think that and
yet desire it so much
I swallowed it I said swallowed it yes I
said go away
and something happened which seems to me
now more terrible than his desire to
corrupt or my thoughtless Act
he began to Weep the tears ran
lopsidedly out of the one good eye and
his shoulders shook I only saw his face
for a moment before he bent his head and
Strode off the bald turnip head shaking
into the dark when I think of it now
it's almost as if I've seen that weeping
for its Inevitable Defeat to try and use
me as a weapon and now I had broken in
its hands and it wept its hopeless tears
through one of blacker's eyes
the black furnaces of Bedwell Junction
gathered round the line the points
switched we were tossed from one set of
rails to another
a spray of Sparks a signal light
changing to Red tall chimneys jetting
into the gray night sky the fumes of
steam from stationary engines half the
cold Journey was over and now remained
the long wait for the slow cross-country
train I said
it's an interesting story I think I
should have given blacker what he wanted
I wonder what he would have done with it
I really believe my companion said that
he would first of all put it under his
microscope before he did all the other
things I expect he had planned
and the hints I said I don't quite see
what you mean by that
oh well he said vaguely you know for me
it was an odd beginning that Affair when
you come to think of it
but I should never have known what he
meant had not his coat when he rose to
take his bag from the rack came open and
disclosed the caller of a priest
I said I suppose you think you owe a lot
to Blacker
yes he said you see I am a very happy
man
that is the end of the story the hint of
an explanation by Graham Greene one of
my favorite short stories and in part
because
how it's framed right it's it's uh you
might say it's a story about conversion
and about
appreciation of things that are
um
debated contested understood as
incredibly meaningful even Supernatural
but it's framed in such a way as to
leave everything open the most that you
get and this is coming from a guy who's
a priest are hints there's no
apologetics there's just hints that
might work for one person but don't work
for another person
so green himself of course is a convert
to the Catholic Church by the time that
he's he's writing this I believe in 1948
and it's a uh it's a really quite
ingeniously
constructed story I think it also has
something to say about how we understand
things by seeing what it is that other
people value or disvalue what they fear
what they desire so well
I'm happy to entertain any questions or
comments that people have I thank you
for sharing this story time with me and
indulging in a reading of one of my
favorite short stories we've done a few
others as well and we've got many many
more to come because I have many uh
stories that I like quite a bit so I
will uh
look in the chat and see if there's
anything that people would like to know
more about or have ideas about or want
to make observations about
um otherwise once we wrap up with this
I'm going to be on my way for my Sunday
visit to see some cats in one of our
local shelters so what have what have
you got those who are listening if
there's anything that you want to
carry on some conversation about
we'll give it a minute uh
to see if anybody writes anything in the
chat otherwise we'll
start wrapping up with this
I will mention too that
green if you haven't read them before
Graham green he is a master short story
teller
and great novelist as well I I got into
him in college and graduate school when
I
um bought a few books by him at a used
bookstore and just loved them devoured
them started you know reading as much as
I could by the guy and then I came
across this story which we've we've used
in reading groups in the past
so it doesn't look like there's any
questions or comments so I guess we'll
finish up here a little bit early thanks
everybody for listening and I recommend
this story
um it's well worth reading and
reflecting on if only for the great
narrative craft that green himself shows
but perhaps also for the ideas that it
conveys so I will see you next time when
we're going to be reading Robert blocks
that Hellbound train so we had a story
about you could say opposition to the
forces of evil and protection of the
good and with the next one we'll have
another Supernatural story but this one
is somebody who's not on the side of God
but at odds with the Devil in a very
different way so I will see you next
time and uh yeah this is quite fun to
read and share these stories
foreign